divers follow a cable leading to the
shipwreck 40 meters under the surface
choppy seas have hindered the search for
bodies inside fewer than a third of the
estimated 500 people on board survived
the Italian coastguard released footage
of its rescue attempt on Thursday as the
migrant ship near the coast passengers
lit a fire to signal for help the fire
spread panic broke out and the boat
capsized few of the passengers could
swim italian officials are shocked at
the tragedy and they fear it won't be
the last inquiry call my soul is
dismayed and my heart is filled with
pain Killa mean but what troubles me
most is what I know to be true the fact
that there is no reason for us to think
that this will be the last time
something like this will happen Journet
para pensar que si el ultimo Bulls Italy
can't process all of the refugees
landing on its coast it says it's been
left on its own by the EU just atomic
Dom level after so many incidents we
expected something to change she says we
hope for change after the Pope came here
in July it can't continue like this or
there will be more disasters like this
in the future that I malkura with the
Gulf
on a visit to SCC Pope Francis appealed
for more compassion for people fleeing
poverty and war calls are mounting for a
new immigration policy to involve the
entire European Union